die kleine stadt augustusburg in sachsen
im erzgebirge ganz in der nähe von
chemnitz nicht einmal 5000 einwohner
wohnen hier und doch auf augustusburg
könnte schon in wenigen tagen ganz
deutschland schauen denn die stadt will
auf machen
trotz steigender corona zahlen
bürgermeister dirk neubauer weil es
wichtig ist weil wir davon ausgehen
können möglicherweise wiederholt sich im
herbst 21 20 und wir müssen gerüstet
sein einfach für kündigt immer das
gesamte leben immer wieder runter fahren
das ist ökonomisch nicht sinnvoll und
das macht auch gesellschaftspolitisch
langsam ein problem ist neubauer etwa
leichte nicht nein er hat ein ganz
klares konzept vor allem mit diesem
schnell testzentrum hier kann sich jeder
bewohner der stadt kostenlos testen
lassen
ist der test negativ gibt es einen 3
tagespass für alle restaurants leben
dienstleistungen freiheit von corona
maßnahmen die digitale eintrittskarte
ins normale leben auf der website der
stadt übersichtlich erklärt
so gibt es einen club da können sich
registrieren kriegen einen primär in
qr-code geschickt dann kann man hier
beim telefon in die rolle packen sondern
ist das jetzt hier gemacht habe und dann
ist hier quasi wie so ein elektronisches
ticket und damit gehe ich jetzt hier ins
testzentrum halte das vor wird
eingescannt dann haben die meine daten
das wird per scan verheiratet mit einem
test mit dem test gehe ich zum
abstrichen verlasse ich ganz schnell
dass hier wieder
wir wollen ja hier auch keine
infektionsketten bilden und kriegt dann
das ergebnis per e mail
und wenn es ein negatives ergebnis ist
wird automatisch im system dieser code
frei geschaltet als die stadt mit
weitsicht so nennt sich augustusburg
selbstbewusst die kleine stadt im
erzgebirge
ein beispiel für ganz deutschland
[Musik]
und hier ist er uns zusätzlich
zugeschaltet dirk neubauer bürgermeister
von augustusburg wir hören die warnungen
hier in der runde auch vor allem von
ihrem parteikollegen karl lauterbach
machen die ihnen angst angesichts
steigender zahlen gerade in sachsen und
wir sind ja nicht leichtfertig
ich denke nur dass wir im
gesellschaftlichen schutz
gesundheitsschutz natürlich auch
aufpassen müssen dass wir den menschen
perspektiven zeigen und ich beobachte
mit sorge gerade im ländlichen raum was
das mit gesellschaft macht und wir
werden an diesen folgenden jahre zu
tragen haben und ich bin überzeugt davon
und das ist ein bisschen in
schwierigkeit in deutschland wir sind in
sachen digitalisierung jetzt nicht so
weit vorn
das sehen wir in allen bereichen und da
gibt es auch eine gewisse skepsis
aber wir haben ganz einfache tools sie
ganz einfache mittel wenn wir die
konsequent anwenden dann kann man das
auch sichergestellt wir sind bild und
wir liefern dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren